so by now everyone has seen the
declassified Pentagon UFO video which is
of course the very first video ever
released on behalf of the United States
government of a so-called UFO or
unexplained aerial phenomena as it's
commonly referred to as and this is a
few things that stuck out to me about
this which in this video I'm going to
connect the dots and some really
interesting pieces of information first
of all let's just address the fact that
this is just another example of the
United States government lying to the
public about the topic of UFOs
for example they claimed for decades
that the last time there was ever a
program to research this topic was
Project Blue Book which ran from 1952 to
1969 but first this just acknowledged
that this 2007 to 2012 22 million dollar
program on the Pentagon like there's no
way that that's the only program they've
had I don't believe it for a second
second of all what about area 51
remember how they lied to the public
about that for so many decades
anyone that talked about it was a
conspiracy theorist and an elune and
ridiculed for it that is until 2013 when
the government themselves acknowledged
that oh yeah it does exist now this also
acknowledged that this story coming out
now about this 2004 incident that these
pilots witness in their f-18s was
obviously a carefully orchestrated
information dump I mean even I mean what
are the odds that the New York Times The
Washington Post and Politico would all
release this story on the exact same day
in fact the Washington Post themselves
state that they had been conducting
confidential interviews for more than
two months on this topic so why is this
all coming out now and this is making a
lot of people think that this is inching
towards alien disclosure that the
government is prepping the masses to get
ready for it and others will say that no
this is simply top-secret technology and
it's a disinformation thing in a PSYOP
and all everything else here's the
bottom line that we all have to realize
and focus on for a moment which is the
fact that we now have scientific
evidence of a craft that defied the laws
of physics and aerodynamics in fact it
had some sort of anti-gravity technology
to where it could just hover without any
type of signs whatsoever of an end
a rotor wings zero exhaust signature no
heat signature and it was capable of
accelerating instantaneously as far as
the eye can see in less than two seconds
you know we also have to keep in mind
real quick that this happened in broad
daylight so when you saw this video
through the IR infrared footage keep in
mind that yeah this is in broad daylight
and here we are we only get just over a
minute of footage of a five minute
incident I want to see the rest of the
video I want to see this thing hovering
I want to see it
skyrocketing off I want to see more but
not only that they acknowledge that they
have recovered material from crashed
unexplained aerial phenomena that is
unknown to science metal alloys
so obviously created by intelligence
that doesn't exist on this planet so I
mean what are they telling us here I
mean could it be any more obvious this
is basically a disclosure and of itself
but not everyone will agree on that some
people are convinced that this is not
aliens and for some reason so many
people have this adverse reaction to the
word aliens
take for example neil degrasse tyson you
may have seen his interviews on this
topic and oh my goodness I mean why he
didn't take it serious at all he laughed
through the old interview he didn't even
answer a majority of the questions and
Sutton you know sidestepped everything
he doesn't even acknowledge at all
whatsoever the fact that it had
anti-gravity technology that it defied
the laws of physics and aerodynamics he
doesn't even acknowledge the fact that
they have materials that are completely
unexplainable to science and it said he
just laughs the whole thing off and you
know this reminds me of a quote by
Aristotle which is it is the mark of an
educated mind to entertain the thought
without accepting it and the only
intelligent thing that Neil deGrasse
said was that look ufos doesn't mean
aliens and yeah I agree it's like duh I
mean that's sure of course but he just
ignores everything else and by the way
for somebody who is so adamant that
humans are destroying the planet he
doesn't even acknowledge the fact that
we now know scientifically that
technology exists that can operate
without a combustion engine that can
hover anti-gravity instantaneous
acceleration and yet here we are filling
up at the gas pump spending all their
money there
the incredible ridiculous prices of
airfare and obviously some sort of clean
technology I mean regardless of whether
this is from ETS or man-made the
technology now exists it's out the cats
out of the bag we know it it's been
disclosed by the government and this
topic isn't even being discussed by any
mainstream media outlet don't you think
that's a little odd and now that we
actually have physical material that is
unexplained to science we know that the
military is handling the whole thing and
we all need to keep in mind that there's
not one single form of technology of any
kind that has not been weaponized just
think about that and it gives credence
to people that are saying that look this
is just an excuse for the government to
spend more money on space weapons I mean
you've probably heard that the
government is looking to create a sixth
branch of the military a space Corps to
go along with the Navy the Marines the
Air Force the army the Coast Guard and
this of course ties into orbital
munitions putting weapons on satellites
which would give any country just
supreme offensive abilities you wouldn't
need aircraft if you could drop bombs
from satellites and this of course ties
into what are called the rods of God
where they have developed a technology
basically you have solid pieces of
tungsten in the shape of a missile
24,000 pounds by the way that have no
explosives of any kind and essentially
is a weaponized meteor
I mean meteors don't have any explosives
right and yet they can destroy well a
whole city a whole planet they can wipe
out all of existence
it's all about that speed and the impact
when it hits so this is the frontier and
it's illegal now but this could be an
example of them trying to push this
forward now something else that needs to
be discussed and I've mentioned in
multiple videos is the Pentagon missing
trillions that are unaccounted for the
Pentagon has without a doubt cooked
their books and this story ties into
August and September of 2016 where every
major media outlet covered this we're
essentially the pent not essentially for
a fact the Pentagon has cooked their
books and this is straight out of their
own mouth that's by the way look into it
but trillions are unaccounted for and
without a doubt it's clearly been
utilized to embezzle or move probably
hundreds of billions of dollars into
black projects because again this story
in itself the Pentagon UFO program was
used with black money where essentially
the Senators Congress
even the president doesn't know where
this money is being used for so we have
to acknowledge that with all this money
and untold amount that is unaccounted
for we have to accept the fact that
maybe just maybe this 2004 video is in
fact us but then the question becomes
how did we figure this out and it of
course gives credence to the stories of
crashed UFOs being found and thus here
we are reverse engineering it but do not
be fooled into thinking for a second
that this is simply just man-made
because the same incident happened in
1952 and it's commonly referred to as
the 1952 lights over Washington DC
incidents where two weekends back to
back the last two weekends of July in
1952 there was many differents sightings
and this was observed from two different
radar systems at two different airports
it was witnessed by many different
pilots both military as well as civilian
including flight attendants and pilots
on the ground as well as in the air and
in fact they even had jets chase down
these objects to no avail as they were
skyrocketing at incredible speeds up
down in every direction in fact they
were witnessed on these radars
documented at more than 7,000 miles an
hour so when I mentioned earlier with
the government lying about UFOs there
their story for this is that well maybe
it was related to you know a weather
inversion that's why the two different
radar systems saw this and it was just
obviously incorrect well hold on a
second
so just never mind what all these pilots
saw nevermind the pilots at JC's craft
and said that they skyrocketed into up
at an incredible rate of speed and
they're doing 90-degree turns at several
hundred miles an hour another excuse Lee
had is that the pilots were seeing a
ferry on the Potomac River headed
towards Mount Vernon okay so first of
all of these pilots yeah they're too
dumb to know the difference between a
plane and a boat but the story is
debunked in itself because in during
this incident
these lights traveled as far away as
Franklin Indiana which of course the
Potomac River doesn't even enter into
Indiana so no it wasn't a ferryboat
but this is all smoke and mirrors guys
they put out a little of information to
confuse people and just have put some
doubt into the air and people just
forget about it but for no reason should
anyone
I mean this is 1952 12 years before the
sr-71 blackbird first test flight even
seven six or seven years before they
even put it on paper and then you have
these crafts traveling at thousands of
miles an hour 90-degree turns at several
hundred miles an hour like no there's no
way that that was some sort of drone
technology and again some people are
saying because of this 2004 video that
look this craft was moving at such
g-forces that the human body could not
possibly survive through so others will
say oh well then it was a drone which
the pilots themselves thought that these
were drones but hold on a second that
reminds me where's the rest of the
footage of these multiple craft all we
see is one you know we need to start
calling this UFO gate we now know the
government themselves have acknowledged
that they have crashed craft that have
materials of unknown scientific origin
they were defying the laws of physics
and aerodynamics and had anti-gravity
technology and everything else
and basically the same thing happened
back in 1952 this raises all kinds of
questions like what does President Trump
say about this his press secretary was
asked and she said she hadn't talked to
him about it and she would get back to
everyone and she never did and I was
like what a week and a half ago which by
the way the whole freakin press room
laughed their asses off when he when the
guy asked oh I have a question about
UFOs like haha so funny right but we
only have to look at what other
presidents have stated about this Barack
Obama and his first term said he had no
knowledge of UFOs and then when he was
asked in his second term he said I can't
reveal anything like how hard is it to
say I don't know or even President
George Bush said the same thing I can't
or I'm not revealing nothing or even
Bill Clinton stated that when he was
president he attempted to receive
information regarding the topic of UFO
UFOs and was access denied so who's
running the show like did I misinterpret
the Constitution here who is really
running things it's obviously not the
president I mean we've long known this
there's something like a dozen security
clearances higher than the precedents
and in the same thing with this black
money that there's information that
exists that the president isn't privy to
guys who's running this show
so yeah President Trump if you are truly
the outsider that you claim to be we
need more information
we need to see videos this is again guys
call this UFO gate
they acknowledge in themselves that
there's at least what four minutes
additionally that we haven't even been
seen and who knows how many other
incidents they do have documentation of
this is where people come out and say oh
well the masses aren't ready for
disclosure humanity can't handle this so
you know maybe you can't handle it or
anyone that can't handle this
information then okay go live under a
rock someplace while the rest of
humanity progresses because it's 2018
the world seems to be getting crazier so
how have being told lies for so long
whether it's by our government and
politicians the news media various
religions and certain aspects of the
scientific community how has that been
working out for us and I should also
mention corporate America and lies that
the CEOs and anything to make a dollar
how of these lies been working out for
us right it's time for us to know the
truth the truth is what humanity needs
but again the bottom line is that we now
know beyond a reasonable doubt that this
phenomena is actually real and so we
need to start taking it seriously and
asking new questions we need to know
what the president thinks about it and
the public has a right to know more
information than this this is ridiculous
so everybody UFO gate put the word out
the more the masses make a big deal and
stink over it the sooner we'll get
answers that's how things work so I'll
leave it at that but leave a comments
let me know what your thoughts are as
well as share other information that
you're aware of involving this topic but
I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe and yeah more videos
coming soon take care everybody